[Musique]
bonjour belfort birota bonjour monsieur
vous êtes le onze candidats à la
sénatoriale du 24 septembre prochain
dimanche
vous avez attendu les tous derniers
jours belfort birota pour officialiser
votre participation à ce scrutin
or en basset vous l'aviez annoncé depuis
fort longtemps
c'est de la coquetterie avant de
répondre à votre question permettez moi
d'avoir une pensée très forte pour nos
concitoyens qui sont victimes de cette
tempête maria
une pensée également pour nos voisins de
dominique c'est vrai que j'ai dû
atteindre le 27 ou 2017 n'est ce pas
lors de la fête du robert pour annoncer
officiellement ma candidature
il faut savoir que je suis de ceux qui
en politique comme dans la vie respecte
certaines condamne hausse il a été dit
selon la rumeur que mes deux deux
présidents de communautés de l'agglo
monsieur monsieur le président de spa
sud
j'ai lâché et j'ai démarché et celui de
cap nord aurait pu être candidat n'est
ce pas aux sénatoriales
vous savez comme moi que je suis en
affinité idéologique avec ses deux
présidents l'a donc la moelle ou les
convenances voudrait en voulu que
j'attende n'est ce pas leur décision a
droit pas de la coquetterie ce n'est pas
de la coquetterie se parent style ouais
j'ai parcouru de nouveau l'interview que
vous avez accordée à france antilles le
4 septembre dernier je découvre un homme
bon à travers vos belfort birota bon
parce que vous ne voulez pas infligé à
votre parti du rdm les déconvenues d'une
éventuelle défaite dimanche prochain il
n'y a pas que ça seulement il ya aussi
le fait que je crois que la fonction de
sénateur est une fonction qui est au
dessus de tout je considère que les
sénateurs ne doit pas s'enfermer dans un
parti politique c'est ça que vous n'avez
pas demandé la visite officielle
investiture officielle de mon temps
intime mais je tiens à dire que tous mes
camarades me soutiennent donc vous êtes
un candidat libre je suis un candidat
libre mais un candidat qui entend rester
au-dessus de la mêlée
oui j'estime qu'un sénateur ne doit pas
être le sénateur le parti la commune et
2007 médiocre comment peut-on tenir un
tel discours devant les grands électeurs
qui sont quand même censé être avertis
un candidat libre mais avant ça fait un
peu gros comme le nid rougerie articles
que vous êtes par exemple tous les goûts
des lecteurs connaissent mon orientation
politique
tous les gosses des électeurs savent que
je suis secrétaire général adjoint du
deuxième et je fais donc appel à
l'intelligence politique des grands
électeurs doit se dépasser pour crazy ce
n'est pas du réglage ce n'est pas de
l'hypocrisie ce n'est pas non plus dans
mes habitudes je suis clair net et
précis le plus souvent est ce que vous
considérez que marius narciso soutenu
par le mime tout comme georges clients
sont des adversaires directs dans ce
scrutin de dimanche prochain
je préfère ne pas faire de commentaires
là dessus pas à chaque partie est libre
de présenter l'école du jogging persuadé
qu'avec tous ces candidats des formes
hirota vous avez mis en avant quand même
pour justifier votre votre présence à ce
scrutin
vous mettez en avant votre longévité est
votre parcours politique
oui quand c'est tout un chacun puisque
comme vous le savez vous avez
l'expérience il faut avoir et c'est l
expérience non seulement de la politique
mais des choses et aussi des thématiques
qui concernent les collectivités
en effet je suis conseil municipal
depuis 1983 aubert j'ai exercé aussi
bien au niveau de la commune toutes les
fonctions possibles imaginables conseil
général du conseil régional de cap nord
de la ctm et de la 7e également ce qui
fait que j'ai connu les périodes de
vaches grasses
j'ai aussi connu je connais à ce moment
les périodes de vaches maigres c'est
comme vous le savez un peu d'espagne au
recul de l'état les communes connaître
le très grande difficulté et c'est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles j'ai voulu
apporter au niveau du sénat tous les
problèmes que connaissent nos
collectivités
on a parlé de votre expérience il y en a
une autre
est très récente celle que vous exercez
en tant que conseiller territorial et là
vous dit très clairement les choses ne
marche pas ça ne fonctionne pas parce
que vous avez hérité d'une d'une
collectivité inachevé dans sa conception
notamment le relationnel entre le
conseil exécutif et l'assemblée de
martinique c'est là que vous vouliez que
vous allez mettre le droit en priorité
là je dois dire que pour ce qui me plaît
et je ne parle pas des hommes je parle
de l'institution elle même comme vous le
savez cette collectivité territoriale
que nous avons appelé le neveu est à mon
avis une construction imparfaite et que
j'estime qu'au moment où je vous parle
nous sommes en train de l'expérimenter
et nous constatons qu'il y a quelques
petits points de blocage notamment et je
le dis parce que je suis un démocrate au
plus profond d'eux mêmes
cette fameuse ce fameux bonus de 11
sièges
mais à mon avis n'est ce pas une
difficulté au niveau de la démocratie je
suis de ceux qui pensent que nous sommes
français nous appartenons la république
française
nous avons des valeurs à défendre nous
devons encore conserver ici une
démocratie j'ai envie de dire parfaite
qui fonctionne très bien
donc il faudrait vite il faut que toutes
les tendances n'est ce pas politique de
ce pays présente aux élections sont
représentés dans ce que j'appelle une
commission parl permanente exactement ce
qui se fait en guyane
la seule manière à mon avis d'assurer
une juste représentation des populations
vous avez bien tir de belfort birota que
vous ne voulez pas attaquer les hommes
et quand même avec d'autres caractères à
la tête de ces deux structures les
choses auraient pu être plus plus
rationnelle plus efficace chacun son
garage agréé à son ego moi j'appartiens
à cette race d'hommes qui veut réunir
les contraire rassembler n'est ce pas
les hommes derrière non pas une bagnole
mais derrière un projet et c'est
pourquoi si les gens me font confiance
je me fais un fort 2 noeuds rapprocher d
oran les moteurs qu'ils soient députés
aux sénateurs pour essayer de bâtir un
projet commun que nous allons d
en somme à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat et pourquoi on vous croirait
davantage vous aujourd'hui belfort
birota tous les autres le disent tous
ceux qui sont candidats disent ouais
nofrag ou même aux élections et puis le
nikkei lundi graines qu'ils descendent
plus forts ceux qui la disent ne
s'appelle pas belfort birota parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les appuis à l'élan
vers le moi je les verts tout le monde
je n'ai de problème avec personne et je
crois qu'il nous faut éviter les erreurs
du passé
un exemple le périmètre de transport
unique que avait été demandée par un de
nos sénateurs
ce projet a été combattu un peu à
l'assemblée nationale par le député au
résultat nous avons pris dur cas
s'agissant de la mise en place de cette
autorité une des transports que chacun
peut aller de ses vues évitons les
erreurs du passé a créé en accueillant
n'est ce pas une nouvelle manière de
fonctionner en faisant fi des clivages
politiques en place l'intérêt général au
centre de nos préoccupations c'est ça
tout ça je veux subir au tas c'est pas
que j'avais le sida
quel thème quels thèmes record pourriez
vous défendre il ya un trou la
martinique qui me tient particulièrement
à coeur cantonniers n'est ce pas de des
problèmes de financement que connaissent
nos collectivités
c'est celui du financement du service
des incendies départ départemental de
président 10 10 le ratio n'est pas
normal il faut que chacun comprenne que
les martiniquais paye deux fois sa
sécurité
une première fois par la ctm dotation de
la ctm une deuxième fois par les
municipalités
donc il faut imaginer un système avec
les autres parlementaires
un projet à présenter au gouvernement à
l'étape où que nous allions vers un
financement eu un manque un mode de
financement unique 12 10 merci d'avoir
été ce matin avec nous il rappelle que
vous êtes peu des deux un des onze
candidats en lice pour les sénatoriales
de dimanche prochain bonne journée merci
merci
[Musique]